[Laughter]
[Music]
nemco makes suitable for vegetarians not
recommended but suitable this looks
really fun there's a lot going on here
look so many flavors I don't recognize
cinnamon and part of all I don't know
what those arts like Chex Mix made of
Cologne
a little spicy ooh it settles really
well it's like what bar food would taste
like cannon fever dream pretty good it's
like I opened every ramen flavor Pat and
poured it into my mouth guys like me who
loves spicy food this would make a
perfect snack dal moon delicious and
crispy this is the most fun it looks
like we got fossilized rice rice
krispies treats it's like if somebody
wanted to like make fries out of rice I
kind of feel like I'm eating dry lentils
I would actually suggest never to eat
this ever he's a great definitely crispy
not quite delicious though okay but
Shashi mix a little bits of crunch
everywhere
it looks like stir fry you've basically
just given me instant ramen I don't know
what this flavor is where it's great
it's really spicy there's one taste like
curry it's really bad it's weird cuz
it's dry but it has the flavor at soup I
don't know why you just don't make this
into a chip Contenta lies all your taste
buds here's my favorite one so far I
probably wouldn't buy some
like everything the next taste comes all
the way from snack city snack city good
snack snack City [ __ ] Chili's yeah with
this little mini french fries yeah they
taste like sticks nice if you think I'm
funny they're really spicy at the end
then aftershock how sweet slow burn I'd
say overall they're super chills
[Music]
Shahin deluxe it's the snack that gives
you cancer don't try this at home kids
look at what it is and we have
McDonald's taste test so this is nothing
smells like grandma's perfume how do you
swallow this it's just in my mouth
surprisingly this is the best thing I
faced at all dad
that's kind of nice oh my teeth are just
like being the way to depart not sure
the end of this what are you guys doing
over there it looks like my mouth is a
waiting room hmm yeah there's a very
crisp and distinct flavor to it I guess
then have some good snacks the finest
ingredients the guarantee both great
taste and a fun time
[Laughter]